so my asking why was that served I said
I got very strong quickly today think
I'd ever say that so let's have some
fine man helmet buddy what do you think
they only need to double XL please go
out on the limb you gonna need a picnic
great that's good so here are my
observations he looks a lot more
comfortable in his drivers suit then you
look like in yours what's your
experience my new outfit right here you
know when you get a new outfit it takes
time to break it in is that it I think
it'll just until my body
you're asking me real important today
you ought to be able to pull up real
good behind the draft he's creating and
I'm not trying to be mean I'm just
making observations and so we know that
today's track is seven tenths of a mile
and it is 11 turns so Dale go ahead
since you set the challenge lay out the
ground rules for today's race I think
that uh mundo four laps I start a lap
behind okay he runs four laps you got to
run five I start lap down I gotta run
five I got to make my lap up passing
okay so we start straight up but at the
end of the day Charles only only has to
complete four laps you complete five
checkered flag and we have a trophy over
there okay let's do it all right Jerry
you can't dream to see to the best
drivers in the world perform at a high
level
so the green flag is in the air and this
challenge is under way and no surprise
Dale Earnhardt jr. gets the early jump
Charles has already lost a ton of ground
is Dale jr. screams down that back
straightaway jr. nearly strides it off
the track as he screams around turn a
but as Dale jr. completes lap number one
Charles now finds himself heading to the
right-hand turn turn nine Charles only
needs to make four laps to win this
thing
rivers gone I will omit them
it's like Charles Barkley is in slow
motion on the track
Charles just finished his second lap
Dale jr. just finished his third here
comes down jr. closing on Charles
Barkley
that was a nice pass for the lead now
junior started this race one lap down
but he showed the true professionalism
that he has cruising to the checkered
flag
Dale Earnhardt jr. winning his five laps
and you look out and here comes Charles
Barkley
but is he not even gonna cross the
start-finish line so it turns out we
need to rethink our plan I don't think
the handicapped work do you anticipated
it working a little better than that
maybe we should give you three you're
given two okay I think we'll do that how
about you run three laps you run two
laps Charles that fair to you as long as
i'm aware this pair you said you're a
little nervous in the turns let's try to
overcome that be a little more
competitive this time around well I I
can't overcome the fact that I'm gutless
going around a curve that's hard to
overcome is it intimidating racing
someone named her heart
no it's intimidating going fast around
curbs it's interesting to me you use the
terminology fast because the see I had I
didn't see a whole lot out of this cart
oh and it's greater where you don't
believe it okay
all right so here we go new lineup Dale
Earnhardt jr. 'he's got to go three laps
Charles has to go to the challenge is on
good luck to you both all right green
flag is out and we are often challenged
number two
and once again Dale Earnhardt jr. taking
the advance
this is in big-time favor of Chuck if he
can somehow pull it off
really picked up speed he's screaming
and Dale can real travel has turned
around over in the middle part of the
course we do have a local caution
Charles gets a turn around driving
through the grass but as he's doing that
Dale jr. completes lap number two and
that gets Earnhardt right back in the
game this is going to be one fantastic
finish
Earnhardt gonna have to gain really
quickly and I believe Charles Barkley
was sandbagging in that opening round
because here he comes off the turn 11
checkered flag in the air and waiting
for Charles Barkley will have to sell
them another day and we're at a three
time now for the trophy presentation and
before we hand out the trophy some
comments about today's race or races
Dale you laid out the challenge your
thoughts of Sir Charles behind the wheel
I think he he tricked me cuz he went
like real slow the first race and then
the next race he all sudden he's winning
so this was like old-fashioned my
strategy was like [ __ ] you know
first I was just nervous to be honest
with you because like I can obviously go
fast in the straightaways but you get
nervous going around the corners and
then the guy my limo driver story yell
at me and told me I couldn't spin out
and I did spin out he sucks at the
driver okay so so for the recap round
one with the Dale Earnhardt jr. with
that nice pass over in this chicane he
gets to hold the trophy so then we went
round to help Charles in the handicap
category and despite spinning out
courtesy of advice from his limo driver
he got the trophy I I think I think
co-champions what do you guys think huh
I think it's TT continue to be continued
perhaps a rematch down the road